marie good morning how are you i'm great
how are you dr john
so good so good how can i help this
morning
yeah well thanks for taking my call my
husband just entered
a rehab program for alcohol how do i
navigate
his return home wow okay
man there's been a bunch of just light
softball tosses of calls today man this
has been a fun has been a fun show
so i'm gonna assume that there is a
trail of wreckage
in your home before your husband decided
to go to rehab is that fair
absolutely yeah okay well it could be
just
we can just take a stroll together
through the wreckage and walk me through
it
sir yeah um so we've been married
for 14 years and
um i really started noticing
a lot of drinking that to me
wasn't really a normal type of behavior
um probably more so when our child was
born and he's nine now
okay um and it seemed to kind of go hand
in hand with some
stress from maybe being a new parent and
just some job changes and things like
that
and it really has gotten
worse in the past probably three or four
years
where he's gone into a detox program
he's had a lot of counseling and things
like that
but this last time we really i i really
kind of gave him an ultimatum that it
had to be
either you need to go and get
actual treatment somewhere or you need
to leave because
all the pressure really has been on me
um
and so you know schooling at home
i'm the only one that works so he hasn't
worked since
um our child was about three
um so it's just been a lot of pressure
and
absolutely a lot of press so i feel like
everything is on my
shoulders and i i'm not getting really a
lot of the support and help that i
really need just to run
day to day have you ever been in a
situation where
you're not safe no has he ever
i would say no as far as like he's made
he's done things that i feel would be
unsafe like
leaving the stove on unattended and
stuff like that but i've never been like
physically unsafe
um has he been faithful to you
yes okay um so
is this a is this a man that you love
deeply and you hurt for or is this a man
you are done with
and your ultimatum was more of a
bluff call i i'm feeling more towards
the latter
because i've just felt like i've just
been really hurt
and really struggling and i feel
so alone yeah absolutely um
how have give me some one or two things
you've tried to do over the years to
reconnect with him five or six years of
not working at all just laying around
drunk and
um how have you tried to bridge that gap
or are you just busy trying to pay the
bills and make sure your your poor kid's
fed and
etc yes how i kind of feel i feel like
i'm trying to get through the day every
single day okay
oh man so number one
this sucks and i wish there was another
way around it um
you've been living by yourself with with
two kids
basically for a long time yeah my guess
also is that your husband's got some
demons in his closets that are
real and gnarly and mean and ugly
and in for lack of better terms he's
been tortured for the last 10 years or
15 years does that excuse him not
working
no does that excuse addiction no
but it does provide a remarkable context
so my guess is
he's got some ugliness in his past is
that fair
i would say so i don't know of the
ugliness specifically
that which is really strange but okay he
has to have something
to explain this so
hey i'm going to be real honest with you
okay
as honest as i possibly can be so you
told them
it's either us or you're going to rehab
and you're getting well
and through his haze
and brokenness and disconnection he
chose you guys
and he chose to go get well and
however misguided that is however much
you think this isn't going to work and
this is another attempt of
xyz um you left
you put the cards on the table and he
said you're right and he went
and the only way people i don't say only
way
it's very hard for folks to come out of
rehab all right let me back up
addiction is a disconnection issue
and when it stems from trauma when
addiction
comes out of the an addiction is just
your body's way of trying to take care
of itself it's trying to numb
hurt inside it's trying to cut wallpaper
over
fractured relationships disconnected
relationships
and it wallpapers over its fear and
alcohol does an
awesome job of literally shoving that
stuff back down underwater
it makes that hurt go away until it
kills you right
until it burns everything around you and
the sucky part about chemical addiction
especially but all addiction is
that it shoves it all under water and
the one thing that can heal people which
is
connection it makes it hard and hard to
be connected right because the person's
an addict and they just
they end up becoming this this selfish
shell of themselves right
and so to tell somebody you got to go
get well
and then you're going to come home and
then to not be fully into him
and i say fully into him not being fully
on board with connecting with him
is going to be is going to be torture
for him
it's going to be really hard his
recovery is going to be his recovery and
you can't fix things for him you can't
make him go to meetings you can't make
him not cheat on you you can't make him
go get a job
um but
him doing these things to try to help
himself be well from the inside out
and then you still have in the back of
your mind i don't love you i don't want
to be with you
i don't want you in my house you disgust
me i'm exhausted by this
um he's going to feel that disconnection
and it's really going to be
a situation where neither of you are
going to end up well out of this deal
and so you have to decide full stop
when he gets out are you going to be
able to move past the last five years
the last nine years
and um here's the here's the way i talk
about after infidelity
it's a very similar situation for you
you can't go back to 911
to the twin towers we could never get
all the dust and twisted metal and glass
and rebuild those two towers as they
were they're gone
but what we can do is excavate the whole
thing
we had a worldwide contest to
a worldwide competition for architects
and design
just savants to to redesign what this
thing was gonna
a new building was gonna look like we
built a monument to what was
we acknowledged it but also we built a
brand new tower together
and that's what it's going to take for
you you're going to be all in and you're
going to have to be graceful you're
going to have to have a detailed
recovery plan of what boundaries look
like for you what you're going to expect
of him
and also you're not going to be able to
just beat him up throughout the entire
process right
remember when remember when remember
when it's going to have to be you guys
united moving forward
and if you're not ready to do that or
you don't want to do that
or you have thoughts in your head about
just him moving out and finally you're
free and you want to
see somebody else and go on down another
road
you owe it to yourself you owe it to him
you owe it to that nine-year-old
child in your house to to make that call
now
so what do you think because i'm talking
yeah i mean
i i agree with you i mean i i've had
mentioned
marriage counseling
i had mentioned marriage counseling in
the past but i always felt this
addiction needed to be
first a thousand percent you cannot go
to marriage counseling if your person if
the person you're with is a drunk you
can't
they've got to get the addiction under
control no question no how
and so what we're talking about is he's
going to go to 30 days
and let's assume let's just go to
fantasy world he completes it with
flying colors
he gets in there and about dave 15 16 he
starts dealing with some old demons
and he starts he goes to group a couple
of times a day he starts to get
one-on-one counseling
he detoxes completely and he comes out
with a
recovery plan in his hand and he comes
with a plan to go to meetings every
every day for 90 days he gets a sponsor
he starts the process
and are you at that point going to look
at him with his new clear eyes
and say there's my guy
let's let's go let's go rebuild
something magical together
or are you gonna go oh god here he is
again
right i need to see proof i need to see
a trap record
you know i need to see that i can trust
him okay i'm going to challenge you okay
all relationship all of the price of
loving somebody deeply
the the price of admission for love is
hurt is pain
it's risk and so if he gets out
and you dangle love in front of him like
a carrot he's going to collapse
you're going to collapse
and i know that's hard and i know that
sets you up to be hurt yet again
but if you say if you do this
then i will slowly reveal myself
re-reveal myself to you
that is like starving somebody
especially an addict who's trying to get
well
[Music]
and so when he comes out accountability
means love
a recovery plan that you both agree to
that means love
i'm not saying he gets to come back in
and move back right back to the couch
and
or he's going to replace he's going to
start running marathons and still not
get a job and still not be present in
all those things
but i mean if you withhold love until he
shows up he will never show up
because that's not how addiction that's
not how healing works
you're going to have to have some strong
boundaries
you're gonna have to have some um some
entrenched things that are gonna be
we are gonna live like this in this
house and then you're gonna have to go
be reckless with your love
you're gonna have to be willing to be
hurt again okay
and if you're not that is okay that's a
decision you made
but i don't want you to torture yourself
i don't want you to torture that little
nine-year-old and i don't want you to
torture this this guy coming out of
rehab
yeah but don't use your love don't use
your body
don't use you the essence of you as a
carrot
you're gonna have to grab his hand when
he comes out and you have to walk
together
also remember in this deal the only
thing in the world and i say this over
and over and over again the only thing
you can control is you
and so you need to make sure this is
going to be a
wonderful time for you to
completely reimagine what life in your
home looks like
what does your wellness plan look like
what does your nutrition and workouts
look like what is your if you're a
person of faith what is
like reestablishing routines around
faith practices look like
um making sure you've got hobbies and
friends that you go
see and you've probably neglected all
that stuff for a decade now
because you've just been trying to
survive you know what i mean it's a
disease of isolation
that's right but it's a disease of
isolation for both parties
right yes and if you looked around my
guess is
you can also become an addict of
planning
an addict of lists an addict of
routine because that's how you've chosen
to survive this you've had to survive it
this way but sometimes those are every
bit the addiction
that alcohol is it's a way that you numb
yourself out it's the way that you don't
feel just so you can survive and alcohol
is the same thing
and so that's why i'm telling you i want
you to make sure you've done this for a
decade now
you've basically been a single parent
with a drunk living on your couch
and you're gonna have to get well too
and you're going to have rage in you
that you haven't felt that you have
you have you have just stuffed down
there as you had
that's what you had to do to survive and
you're going to have pain
and loneliness you have stuff down
you're gonna have to let let that let
out
and that's why the only person you can
deal with on this deal is you
and so i i please for your sake for that
little that little nine-year-old sake
for his sake go get a counselor today
if you don't have one and start making a
plan together for when he gets out what
are your boundaries gonna be
what are the what's it what's an
accountability plan gonna look like for
the two of you
what are the things you need and then
how do you start
like just anchoring in so that when he
does come out
you're not gonna hold him hostage with
love you're not gonna hold him hostage
with
intimacy with physical intimacy if you
do these things then we'll sleep
together if you do these things then
we'll go on a date if you do these
things then i will
slowly let myself no you can't do that
once you set those boundaries once you
say you're welcome back in this home we
are all in this and we're going to
rebuild a new tower together for the
rest of our lives
and i think you can if he truly
is puts the addiction in his rear view
mirror and he does the things on a daily
basis to keep himself whole and well
man i've just seen it over and over you
can it's going to be hard but you can
but he's going to need full you and you
can only have full you if you've got a
community if you've got your own
physical and mental wellness you're
prioritizing you're putting on your
oxygen mask first
you and that nine-year-old are spending
close quality time together not survival
time but close quality time together
and then then the sky's the limit and it
can be a beautiful thing
but if you're out you got to be out if
you are
out you got to be out
so when you hang up on this call your
first call is to a counselor
set up an appointment and say here's
where i'm at and i need a professional
start walking with me
i am so grateful grateful grateful for
this call
and there's so many people whose
husbands and wives head off to rehab
whose husbands and wives
they have hard conversations they have
clearing the debt conversations and then
they start over the next day
and then they don't nobody knows what to
do right it's like all right we're gonna
step up tomorrow
and then tomorrow happens so good for
you marie
for calling i appreciate the call and
either be all in or all out
and either way you're gonna need
somebody to walk with you